ma question s'adresse à la première
ministre dans son immense majorité le
pays a dit son indignation devant la
mort du jeune Naël et depuis mercredi je
ne cesse de croiser des gens en colère
devant les violences et les destructions
inacceptables l'heure doit être à
l'apaisement mais les appels à l'unité
et à la fermeté ne suffiront pas aussi
indispensable soit-il il ne faudra pas
regarder ailleurs une fois le calme
revenu je veux d'abord ici rétablir une
vérité non il n'y a pas de territoire
perdu de la République il n'y a
il n'y a que des territoires que la
République abandonne
ainsi
assis depuis 2005
ainsi depuis 2005 hormis la rénovation
urbaine tous ces dégradés notamment
l'école
qui devrait être la prunelle de nos yeux
et qui est le service public le plus
maltraité l'école est maltraité car les
moyens alloués par le biais de la
politique de la ville ne compense jamais
l'affaiblissement des politiques de
droit commun maltraités car dans le
secondaire il faudrait 45000 personnes
de plus pour retrouver le taux
d'encadrement de 2006 or en 6 ans vous
avez supprimé 8900 emplois
maltraités quand dans l'académie de
Créteil écoutez-moi bien on admet au
concours de professeurs avec une note de
4 sur 20 alors que le seuil est de 14
sur 20 dans le reste de la France et
qu'en plus on s'apprête à pouvoir les
postes par le recrutement sur leboncoin
ou par des jobs dating ce n'est ce n'est
pas ça l'école de la République Monsieur
le Ministre nous croyons encore au mot
de Victor Hugo selon lesquelles quand on
ouvre une école on ferme une prison nous
croyons que l'école est une partie de la
solution ma question quelle mesure
entendez-vous
merci beaucoup le temps est largement
dépassé la parole est à Monsieur Papen
Diagne ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Stéphane peu non la République
n'abandonne aucun territoire l'éducation
nationale n'abandonne aucun territoire
elle n'abandonne pas les filles et les
filles de la République dans le
département que vous citez la scène
Saint-Denis les moyens d'enseignement à
leur même que la population scolaire va
baisser notablement l'année prochaine
les moyens d'enseignement restent au
même niveau
et Monsieur le Député c'est pour cela
que nous augmentons
est-ce que vous pouvez un peu de respect
d'abord pour les enseignants y compris
les enseignants contractuels d'une part
laissez-moi m'exprimer un peu
s'il vous plaît allez un peu de calme un
podcast monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole que nous faisons en scène
Saint-Denis particulièrement ça a été
ça a été monsieur le député le
dédoublement le dédoublement des classes
de CP de C1 de grande section ça a été
les colos apprenantes ça a été les 12
cités éducatives qui ont été créés ces
dernières années ce sont des moyens
d'enseignement supplémentaires se sont
bientôt l'ouverture de toute petite
section c'est aussi également les
horaires en scolaire et en périscolaire
étendu de si de 8h le matin jusqu'à 18h
c'est également à la rentrée 2024 les
bourses scolaires qui seront versées
automatiquement sans que les personnes
aient aller réclamer c'est enfin un plan
pour les 40 collèges les plus en
difficulté sur les 130 oui ça vous
intéresse pas à ma réponse et bien je
vous la donne parce que je m'intéresse à
la Seine-Saint-Denis et je n'en fais pas
un argument de politique politicienne
monsieur le député merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre